So hi everybody. Hey, I like starting an episode with so we're mid conversation. So anyway, welcome to smart less. Lattice. Smart. Lattice. Smart. Lattice. Listener, you'll have to excuse Will Arnett today. The things are a little sour.
所以大家好。嘿，我喜欢用“所以”来开始一集，因为我们是在对话中途切入的。所以无论如何，欢迎收听 smart less。Lattice。Smart。Lattice。Smart。Lattice。听众朋友们，今天你们得原谅威尔·阿奈特。大家的火气有点大。
And surly. He's surly today. He's surely surly. We recorded this the day after my beloved Toronto Maple Leafs lost. Oh, they lost last night? Game seven, yeah. Oh, I'm sorry. And it wasn't a great performance.
而且脾气暴躁。他今天脾气很暴躁。他确实很暴躁。我们录制这期节目的那天，正是我挚爱的多伦多枫叶队输球的第二天。哦，他们昨晚输了？第七场，对。哦，我很遗憾。而且表现确实不怎么样。
Biz made that very clear. Yeah, he sure did. And God bless him for being honest. God bless Biz, Paul Bizonet, my friends, and my co-mourner as a Lease fan. Paul Bissonnette, world's number two Lease fan, obviously, behind me, but I am considering free agency. This is hockey, listener.
比兹说得非常清楚。对，他确实说了。上帝保佑他能实话实说。上帝保佑比兹，保罗·比佐内特，我的朋友，也是我这个枫叶队球迷的共同哀悼者。保罗·比佐内特，世界排名第二的枫叶队球迷，显然在我后面，但我正在考虑成为自由球员。这是冰球啊，听众朋友们。
Yeah, we're talking NHL hockey. I'm considering free agency. No, no, you did say before we started recording, you weren't considering it. You had declared that you are free agent that I want to test the open market I I see how it goes now in the world. We'd love to have you over at the King's okay Well, I'm open to I'd love to hear from Luke Robitaille when the time is appropriate Like to see what kind of package you could put before me
对，我们在谈论NHL冰球。我正在考虑成为自由球员。不，不，你在我们开始录音之前确实说过，你不是在考虑。你已经宣布你是一名自由球员，我想试水自由市场，我看看现在世界上情况如何。我们很乐意邀请你来国王队，好啊，好吧，我持开放态度，如果时机合适的话，我很想听听卢·罗比泰尔的意见。想看看你能为我开出什么样的筹码。
How do you think how do you think Brendan Shanahan is gonna feel about all this run in your mouth here? How do you think Brendan Shanahan's going to feel about all this run in your mouth here, you know? Well, my, look, look, obviously I just do this to- Brendan runs a team there up there in GZERO. Former Smartless guest early on, and friend of ours. He runs a team there at Toronto, and he's having a tough day today, I'll bet. He knows it's a business.
你觉得，你觉得布伦丹·沙纳汉听到你在这里大放厥词会有什么感觉？你觉得布伦丹·沙纳汉听到你在这里大放厥词会有什么感觉，你知道的？好吧，我的，看，看，显然我这么做只是为了——布伦丹在那边 GZERO 管理着一支球队。早期的 Smartless 嘉宾，也是我们的朋友。他在多伦多管理着一支球队，我敢说他今天日子不好过。他知道这是一笔生意。
What, your heart is a business? My fandom. You know that fandom is a- You're not going to stick with them when they're hurting? I'm going to do what's right. I mean, look, it's a business. What, your heart is a business? My fandom. You know that fandom. You're not going to stick with them when they're hurting? I'm going to do what's right. I mean, look, it's nothing wrong. People test the open market. He's tested the open market before.
什么，你的心是一笔生意？我的球迷身份。你知道球迷身份——他们受伤时你不打算支持他们了？我要做正确的事。我是说，听众朋友们，这是一笔生意。什么，你的心是一笔生意？我的球迷身份。你知道球迷身份。他们受伤时你不打算支持他们了？我要做正确的事。我是说，听众朋友们，这没什么不对的。人们会试水自由市场。他以前也试水过自由市场。
He's been a free agent. Oh, do you think he's got his resume out there amongst all the clubs saying, hey, I'd love to be GM over on your? What do I know? I think they need you now more than ever. What do I know? I tell you what I-
他当过自由球员。哦，你觉得他是不是把简历投给各大俱乐部，说，嘿，我想当你们那边的总经理？我懂什么？我觉得他们现在比任何时候都更需要你。我懂什么？我告诉你我——
What do you want to do? You want to run a team, Will? No, he's just looking for a team to root for that's going to win all the time. They're going to win the Stanley Cup every year. They've never won. They've never won in my lifetime. What, the Maple Leafs have never won?
你想做什么？你想管理一支球队吗，威尔？不，他只是在找一支能一直赢球的球队来支持。他们每年都要赢得斯坦利杯。他们从来没赢过。在我有生之年他们从来没赢过。什么，枫叶队从来没赢过？
I've never won in my lifetime. Wow. 1967, it was like- That's like the Cubs to me, and then when they won I cried. Yeah, is that true? 1967 was the last time that they won? Yeah, that's right.
在我有生之年我从来没赢过。哇。1967年，这就像——这对我来说就像小熊队一样，然后他们夺冠时我哭了。真的吗？1967年是他们最后一次夺冠？对，没错。
Will, you were born in 58. I know, so. Ha ha ha. Ha ha ha. Ha ha ha. It's good stuff, it's good stuff. Anyway, what else is going on? Ah, I thought you guys looked handsome today. What else is going on?
威尔，你58年出生。我知道，所以。哈哈哈哈。哈哈哈哈。哈哈哈哈。真有意思，真有意思。不管怎样，还有什么新鲜事？啊，我觉得你们今天看起来很帅。还有什么新鲜事？
Yeah. I didn't even come to Sunday Funday, although I wasn't invited, as it turned out. Oh, now let's, it's subject number two to get all pissed off about. I don't give a fuck. We got a list. Well, what do you mean you weren't invited?
对。我甚至都没去周日狂欢日，虽然结果证明我根本没被邀请。哦，现在我们来谈谈第二个让人抓狂的话题。我才不在乎呢。我们有个名单。什么叫你没被邀请？
You don't know that. Yeah, I do. I sure do. Really fuck. We got a list. What do you mean you weren't invited? You don't know that. Yeah, I do. Really? I sure do. Did you? Tell my inbox. You didn't miss much.
你不知道那回事。不，我知道。我当然知道。真他妈的。我们有个名单。什么叫你没被邀请？你不知道那回事。不，我知道。真的吗？我当然知道。你去了吗？问问我的收件箱。你没错过什么。
It was just burgers and chat. And that's it. Typical Sunday fare. Yeah, sorry. I'm also a free agent with that one. I'm a free agent with Friends now, too. Oh, really? You're looking for a new date for Sunday nights?
也就是汉堡和聊天。仅此而已。典型的周日聚会。好吧，抱歉。对于那件事，我也是个自由球员。我现在和朋友们也成自由球员了。哦，真的吗？你在为周日晚上找新约会对象吗？
Are you drinking dish washing soap? It's water. Why don't you try going to Mass on Sunday nights? Do they have it at night on Sunday or is that Saturday night? Mass. Mass, isn't that what they call it? Yeah.
你在喝洗洁精吗？那是水。你为什么不尝试在周日晚上去望弥撒呢？他们周日晚上有弥撒，还是那是周六晚上？弥撒。弥撒，他们不这么叫吗？对。
Lord's house is always open pal. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Will, I'm really sorry. I sent you a text early yesterday that speaking of Jesus, that I had spoken to hockey Jesus and that Toronto was gonna be okay. And I guess. I know, you weren't alone.
主的殿永远向朋友敞开。对，对，对。威尔，我真的很抱歉。昨天一早我给你发了一条短信，说到耶稣，我说我跟冰球耶稣聊过了，多伦多会没事的。我想。我知道，你不是一个人。
I don't blame, first of all, I'm not superstitious in that way. I was texting with Ham, with John Ham during the game and one of the refs, I'm not laughing at his misfortune, went down because he took a high stick. And he was bleeding. Yeah, he took his stick right in the eye. Yeah, and he was bleeding all over the ice.
首先我不怪你，我不是那种迷信的人。比赛期间我一直在跟哈姆、跟乔恩·哈姆发短信，其中一个裁判——我不是在嘲笑他的不幸——因为吃了一个高杆犯规而倒地了。而且他在流血。对，他的冰球杆直接戳到了眼睛里。对，冰面上到处都是血。
And Ham said, is this good luck or bad luck for your team? And I said, you know, like literally in real time as it was happening, I said, I don't know. I'm actually not superstitious in that way anymore, because then you're just a maniac. So I don't knock wood anymore, I don't do any of that stuff, like who knows?
哈姆问，这对你们球队是好运还是厄运？我说，你知道的，就当时事情发生的时候，我说，我不知道。其实我不再那么迷信了，因为那样你就会变成一个疯子。所以我不再敲木头了，我再也不做那些事了，谁知道呢？
So anyway, I'm letting you off the hook. Look what happened. But this is what I worry about, because I knock wood all the time. I got a whole series of things. I do too, yeah. And Will, you said that you've stopped knocking on wood. Look what happened to your team last night.
所以无论如何，我放你一马。你看发生了什么。但这就是我担心的地方，因为我一直在敲木头。我有一系列的事情要做。我也是，对。威尔，你说过你不再敲木头了。看看你球队昨晚的下场。
Years ago. Yeah. Okay, well this is the problem. This is why you have to keep up with superstition so that you can get the wins when you need them. No, but thinking that- Your fault. Thinking about me watching the game a certain way or doing things a certain way
几年前。对。好吧，这就是问题所在。这就是为什么你得保持迷信，这样在你需要的时候才能赢得比赛。不，但是认为——这是你的错。认为我以某种方式看比赛或者以某种方式做事
and thinking that's gonna affect the outcome, he's like, that's how Charles Manson thought. Do you know what I mean? Like, that's insane. Let's bring a serial killer into it. Will, you need to stop watching sports. Listen, I'm, this is. And stop fucking with your hair, okay?
并认为这会影响结果，这就像——查尔斯·曼森就是这么想的。你知道我的意思吗？这太疯狂了。把一个连环杀手扯进来了。威尔，你得停止看体育节目了。听着，我是说，这是。还有别老他妈的弄你的头发了，行吗？
Here's the other thing I wanna say, is that my Liverpool won the Premier League this year. So that's the good news. There we go. That's the good news. Start singing the song right now. We've conquered all of Europe. We're never gonna stop.
我还想说的是，我的利物浦今年赢得了英超联赛冠军。所以这是个好消息。这就对了。这是个好消息。现在就开始唱这首歌吧。我们征服了整个欧洲。我们绝不会停下。
From Paris down to Turkey. We've won the fucking lot. Is that the chant that they do at the end of that? Oh, that's the chant. The Pink Floyd song. You Never Walk Alone. Fearless. One of my favorite songs ever.
从巴黎到土耳其。我们他妈的赢了一切。这是他们在那首歌最后喊的口号吗？哦，就是那个口号。平克·弗洛伊德的歌。你永不独行。无畏。我最喜欢的歌之一。
With hope in your heart. In your name. The Pink Floyd song, Fearless, one of my favorite songs ever. With hope in your heart, you'll never walk alone. You'll never walk alone. Walk on. Sean, you don't know this stuff. Never walk alone, but that's like an old, old, old song. What is it, Jerry the Pacemaker's, I think? Listen, it's a brilliant song, it's a brilliant team, and yeah, Liverpool.
带着心中的希望。以你的名义。平克·弗洛伊德的歌《无畏》，我最喜欢的歌之一。带着心中的希望，你将永远不会独行。你将永远不会独行。继续走吧。肖恩，你不知道这些东西。永不独行，但这就像是一首非常非常老的歌。是什么来着，好像是 Gerry and the Pacemakers 的吧？听着，这是一首精彩绝伦的歌，这是一支伟大的球队，是的，利物浦。
I'm also, you know, because I'm, anyway, we've spent way too much time on this. How are other things? No, tell me. Let's talk about other things in your life, Will. Yeah, go, tell me, because I got, what let's go either get a hat or fucking turn your camera off I can't see you continuing to fuck with your hair these headphones are driving me crazy cuz I'm wearing over-the-ear headphones today It's well, that's what we all do. Okay, okay
我也，你知道的，因为我是，不管怎样，我们在上面花的时间太多了。其他事情怎么样？不，告诉我。我们聊聊你生活中的其他事情吧，威尔。对，说吧，告诉我，因为我——要么戴顶帽子，要么把你的摄像头关掉，我可受不了你继续弄你的头发了，这些耳机快把我逼疯了，因为我今天戴的是耳罩式耳机。好吧，这就是我们所有人都在做的。好吧，好吧
Why is it a problem? Where's your earbuds? So what then then mute my camera? What how do you do it my camera where your earbuds I knew I needed new friends where your earbuds hey calm down by the way if there's a if there's a wrong side of the bed that you've sure woke up on it speaking of the bed where are you will where's you got this nice curtain behind you and a little leather self. A new whisper booth. I'm in a new, no, no, no, I'm just in my spot here. All right, anything else to chat about before we get to our guest?
这有什么问题？你的耳塞呢？那好吧，那就把我的摄像头静音！你怎么弄的？我的摄像头在哪？戴上你的耳塞。我知道我需要新朋友了。戴上你的耳塞。嘿，冷静点，顺便说一句，如果你今天起床时踩到了不好的那一边——说到床，你在哪，威尔？你身后有这么好看的帘子和一个小皮沙发。一个全新的静音舱。我在一个新的——不，不，不，我只是在我的老地方。好了，在我们迎接嘉宾之前，还有什么要聊的吗？
We have a nice guest today. No, let's stop picking on me. Let's stop picking on me. Sean, what about you? What are your problems today? I can tell you. You gotta go ahead and tell him. Okay.
我们今天有一位很棒的嘉宾。不，别再挑剔我了。别再挑剔我了。肖恩，你呢？你今天有什么问题？我可以告诉你。你赶紧告诉他吧。好吧。
I know what's going on. I gotta accept eating sugar. Listen, I had to go through a night last night with Sean, really boring all of us with the big efforts he's making to get off of sugar. It's been 48 hours, he's just talking about how he's white knuckling and how tough he is. As he's taking sips, deep sips of cranberry juice on ice.
我知道是怎么回事。我得接受吃糖的事。听着，昨晚肖恩一直在让我们所有人都感到无比厌烦，他大肆宣扬自己为了戒糖所付出的巨大努力。这已经是48小时了，他一直在说他是怎么咬紧牙关坚持的，以及他是多么坚强。一边说着，一边深深地抿着加冰的蔓越莓汁。
Well, but that's just red sugar. Juices, sugar, you can't drink that. Yeah, but that, your body, tell us. What is it? What is it, Doc? Processes that kind of sugar differently because it's not processed sugar. Oh, no shit.
好吧，但那是红糖。果汁里有糖，你不能喝那个。对，但那个，你的身体，告诉我们。那是什么？那是什么，医生？处理这种糖的方式不同，因为它不是加工糖。哦，真他妈的。
Got it, yeah. So that won't, okay. Fuck, you know all the stuff behind you, are those diplomas behind you? Yeah. And then what happened when the dessert came to the table last night? I had one bite and I gave the rest to Maple, your daughter.
明白了，对。所以那不会，好吧。操，你身后的那些东西是什么，那是你身后的文凭吗？对。然后昨晚甜点端上桌时发生了什么？我吃了一口，剩下的我都给梅普尔了，你女儿。
I had one bite. That's it? Yeah, but that was good, that was really hard. And then I got home and I've just been shoving fruit in my mouth like crazy, like watermelon and oranges. I'm not really saying you can insert a joke here, but you know. Uh.
我吃了一口。就这样？对，但这已经很棒了，这真的很难。然后我回到家，就开始疯狂地往嘴里塞水果，比如西瓜和橙子。我不是真的在暗示你可以在这里插个笑话，但你知道的。呃。
You know. Insert, yeah, I eat just shoving fruit in my mouth all day. I'm not gonna do a weird joke here, but you know. Uh. You know. Yeah, it's just shoving fruit in my mouth all day. Did fruit mind, did fruit mind or? Does he mind being called that? Oh my God. And Jay lamented over me not having dad jokes, so I have always prepared now. I'll have a dad joke.
你知道的。插个，对，我整天都在往嘴里塞水果。我才不会在这里讲什么奇怪的笑话，但你知道的。呃。你知道的。对，就是整天往嘴里塞水果。水果介意吗，水果介意还是？他介意被这样称呼吗？哦，天哪。杰伊还抱怨我不会讲老爸笑话，所以我现在随时准备着。我会讲一个老爸笑话。
How would you have any dad jokes? What do you mean? You have no dad. Yeah, remember he sped off? Well, that's a good one. No, but I have those prepared. That's a literal dad joke. Yeah, what was the one you told me last night
你怎么可能会讲老爸笑话？什么意思？你没有爸爸。对，还记得他开车疾驰而去吗？好吧，这个不错。不，但我准备好了。这是一个字面意义上的老爸笑话。对，你昨晚跟我讲的是哪个
that we had to work on a little bit? That wasn't very good, that wasn't very good. That was, well, I have one for you really quick, ready? Okay, sure. Knock, knock. Who's there? I eat mop. I eat mop who?
我们还得稍微琢磨一下的那个？那个不太好，那个不太好。那是，好吧，我这儿立刻有一个给你，准备好了吗？好的，当然。咚，咚。是谁呀？我吃拖把。我吃拖把谁？
What happened there? How'd you do that to me? Okay, guys, our next guest was in one of my favorite films of the year. He seems to have it all. He's talented, he's successful, he works with only the top people in the best projects. He's got artistic credibility and box office sock. Okay, that's what you want. You want box office sock.
刚才那是怎么回事？你怎么对我使这招？好吧，伙计们，我们的下一位嘉宾出演了我今年最喜欢的电影之一。他似乎拥有一切。他才华横溢，取得巨大成功，只与最顶尖的人合作最好的项目。他既有艺术信誉，又有票房号召力。好吧，这正是你想要的。你想要票房号召力。
Okay, he's handsome, he's tall, he's got good hair. Let's get him out here. let's see if he's single. Let's see how he does it all. Gang, it's Nicholas Holt. Come on out Nicholas. Hey! What a reveal. Nicholas Holt!
好吧，他长得很帅，个子高，头发很好。让我们把他请出来吧。看看他是不是单身。看看他是怎么做到这一切的。大家伙儿，他就是尼古拉斯·霍尔特。请出来吧，尼古拉斯。嘿！多么惊艳的亮相。尼古拉斯·霍尔特！
Nicholas Holt. It took everything in my power when you were talking about fruit not to reveal myself right there. Now you know how I feel. Well let's get right to it then. So are you single? No I'm not, I'm married.
尼古拉斯·霍尔特。刚才你们在讨论水果的时候，我费了九牛二虎之力才忍住没有暴露自己。现在你们知道我的感受了。那我们言归正传吧。你单身吗？不，我不是，我结婚了。
Oh you are! I've got blonde hair now. You said good hair in the intro as well. Well blonde can be good. Thanks. It was giving me quite a lot of anxiety sitting there. I mean I was enjoying listening to you guys, but also I was like this is quite stressful. The reveal thing.
哦，原来如此！我现在留着金发。你在开场白里也说我头发很好。金色也可以很好嘛。谢谢。坐在那里让我感到非常焦虑。我是说，我很享受听你们说话，但同时我也觉得这压力挺大的。这种揭秘环节。
I mean obviously Jason, you know, it's me. But then I was like, what if quite stressful, the reveal thing. The reveal, oh wait, so. I mean, obviously Jason, you know it's me, but then I was like, well, short and little, like, who, why, no. I know, right, that must be. Wait, you guys know each other? A tiny bit, it must be stressful for the guest, right? This whole sort of like, you're thinking there, well, when I reveal, are they going to be excited,
我是说很显然，杰森，你知道是我。但后来我想的是，多大压力啊，揭秘环节。揭秘，哦等等，所以。我是说很显然，杰森，你本来就知道是我，但后来我想的是，又矮又小，比如，谁，为什么，不。我懂，对吧，那一定。等等，你们认识彼此？一点点，对嘉宾来说一定压力很大，对吧？这种感觉就是，你在想，好吧，等我揭晓的时候，他们会兴奋呢，
are they going to be disappointed, are they going to, do they know, right? Is that what the thing is? Well, yeah, because if I were you, I'd probably be quickly Googling like Nicholas Horton. Well that whole line, it's the whole reason we do the surprise guest thing. You're a big star, we don't need to.
还是会失望，他们会，他们知道吗？是这样吗？嗯，是的，因为如果我是你的话，我可能会赶紧去谷歌一下“尼古拉斯·霍特”。这就是我们搞神秘嘉宾的全部原因。你是个大明星，我们不需要。
The other two people don't have to do any research. So Will and Sean get to just sit here and be the dummies that they are. No, of course I know. I could ask you a thousand questions about Nosferatu, which you were amazing, I love that movie. Not a question, that was a statement No, of course I know. I could ask you a thousand questions about Nosferatu, which you were amazing. I love that movie. I mean, anything.
另外两个人根本不需要做什么调查。所以威尔和肖恩就可以坐在这里，当他们那样的傻瓜。不，我当然知道。我可以问你关于《诺斯费拉图》的一千个问题，你在里面演得太棒了，我超喜欢那部电影。这不是问题，那是个陈述句。不，我当然知道。我可以问你关于《诺斯费拉图》的一千个问题，你在里面演得太棒了。我超喜欢那部电影。我是说，任何问题。
Not a question, that was a statement. Go over the first question. No, but I have a question. The thousand questions. I want the makeup. The thousand questions, go. Okay, ready? The makeup, what was it like?
这不是问题，那是一个陈述句。进行下一个问题。不，但我有个问题。那剩下一千个问题。我想问化妆的事。那一千个问题，问吧。好吧，准备好了吗？化妆，那是什么感觉？
Like, what was the reverse of it? 999 to go, go ahead. Wait, why is your hair blonde? I'm saying you have a thousand, just ask a question. I'm holding everybody's feet to the fire. Nicholas, I've had a rough 24 hours. He really has. I know, I'm sorry, I heard and I'm sorry.
比如，卸妆是什么样的？还剩999个，继续。等等，为什么你的头发是金色的？我刚说你有一千个问题，随便问一个吧。我这是在逼大家表态呢。尼古拉斯，我度过了艰难的24小时。他确实挺难的。我知道，我很抱歉，我听说了，也很遗憾。
You'll get through. Wait, why is the hair blonde? What's coming up for you? I can't, but you know, you work in only the greatest projects. I mean, your resume is really stunning. The Order. When do you stop? That's the film, that was one of my favorite films
你会挺过去的。等等，为什么头发是金色的？你接下来有什么新作品吗？我不能说，但你知道的，你只参与最棒的项目。我是说，你的履历真的很惊艳。游牧人。你什么时候收手？那是那部电影，那是我今年最喜欢的电影
of the year. Incrediblog. The Order is where we met because you were working with Jude on your show and you came in very nicely When do you stop? That's the film, that was one of my favorite films of the year. Incredible. That's where we met because you were working with Jude on your show and you came in very nicely for the Q&A for us. Thank you for doing it. Same director, right? Yeah, that was really fun. Yeah, Justin Kurzel, yep.
之一。难以置信。我们在《游牧人》片场认识的，因为你当时在你的剧组和裘德一起工作，你非常友善地来参与我们的问答环节。谢谢你百忙之中抽空过来。同一个导演，对吧？对，那真的很有趣。对，贾斯汀·库泽尔，没错。
Incredibly well-directed film. And then he directed the final two episodes of Black Rabbit and that guy is just incredible. Did you have fun with Justin? Yeah, I love that guy. Thank God, he's so good at what he does. Anyway, why is the hair blonde? What's coming up?
一部导演功力极其深厚的电影。然后他还执导了《黑兔》的最后两集，那家伙简直太棒了。你和贾斯汀合作得开心吗？对，我超喜欢那个家伙。谢天谢地，他在他的领域太厉害了。不管怎样，为什么头发是金色的？接下来有什么安排？
What's that for? This is a movie I'm about to start called, it's called How to Rob a Bank. Oh, with David Leach, who was just on the show. Oh yeah. David's directing. Oh yeah, that's great. He called me the other day and he was like,
那个是为什么拍的？这是我马上要开拍的一部电影，叫做，叫做《如何抢劫银行》。哦，和大卫·雷奇合作，他刚上过这个节目。哦，对。大卫在执导。哦，太棒了。他前几天给我打电话说，
how would you feel about going blonde and trying that for this? And I was like, yeah, okay, so I went into my wife's aunt's salon yesterday and bleached my hair. And here I am, yeah, okay. So I went into my wife's aunt's salon yesterday and bleached my hair. And here I am. Oh, look at that. You went to your wife's aunt's?
你觉得把头发染成金色来试试这个角色怎么样？我说，好吧，所以我昨天去了我妻子阿姨的美发沙龙，把头发漂白了。然后我就在这儿了，对，好吧。所以我昨天去了我妻子阿姨的美发沙龙，把头发漂白了。然后我就在这儿了。哦，瞧瞧。你去了你妻子阿姨开的店？
So this is like my big reveal to you three guys. So tell me how it looks. Listen, Nicholas, let's give a plug, because we plug hairdressers on this show a lot. So let's give a plug for salon. You got Skebo, you got Chris McMillan. Salon Midori. Salon Midori.
所以这是我对你们三个人的重大揭秘。快告诉我看起来怎么样。听着，尼古拉斯，我们得打个广告，因为我们在节目里经常给美发师打广告。所以给这家沙龙做个广告吧。你有斯基博，你有克里斯·麦克米兰。美智子沙龙。美智子沙龙。
Where is it? Where is it, Nicholas? Hang on, I can give you the full address. Get ready, listener. This gives you time to get your pen ready, listener. It's in Brea, California. Okay. Oh yeah, fantastic.
在哪儿？在哪儿，尼古拉斯？等等，我可以把完整地址给你。听众朋友们，准备好。这给你们时间准备好笔了，听众朋友们。它在加利福尼亚州的布雷亚。好的。哦，太棒了。
Ask for Lay Cicero. Done. Just say the word smartless and receive up to, I don't know, I'm just saying. Yeah. Wait, Nicholas, by the way, Nick or Nicholas, what's your name? Nick's good, yeah.
找雷·西塞罗。搞定。只要说出“smartless”这个词，就能获得最高，我不知道，我只是随便说说。对。等等，尼古拉斯，顺便问一下，叫你尼克还是尼古拉斯？叫尼克就行，对。
Okay, so Nick, where are you right now? I'm in Long Beach, we live down in Long Beach. And is this where you live? Yeah. Oh wow, that's nice. How long have you been here in the States? Coming up on like seven years, I think. But like, you know, kind of roaming around
好吧，尼克，你现在在哪？我在长滩，我们住在长滩。这是你常住的地方吗？对。哦，哇，真不错。你在美国待了多久了？快七年了吧，我想。不过在这期间，你知道的，到处漂泊。不过是的，在长滩已经住了大约两年了。话说你是怎么发现长滩这个地方的？对于听众朋友们来说，如果你对洛杉矶不太了解的话，长滩是这座城市里一个不可思议的地方。洛杉矶港就在长滩。我认为是全国最大的港口。这里并不是你经常听到人们居住的地方，因为它就在城市的南边
throughout all that time as well. But yeah, been down in Long Beach for like two. Now how did you find Long Beach? This is, for listener, if you're not aware of Los Angeles, Long Beach is an incredible part of the city. It's the port of Los Angeles, it's in Long Beach. The largest port in, I think, the country. And it is not a place that you often hear people living in because it's just south
城市的南边。还有商业区。还有商业区。还有商业区。因为它就在城市的南边。所以我很想知道你是怎么找到那里的。我妻子的家人都住在这一带。所以由于我经常要在路上奔波，离她更近一些，让她周围能有一个支持系统，这样就很合乎逻辑了。老实说，我很喜欢这里。洛杉矶总有些东西让我
of the city. And the business. And the business. And the business. Because it's just south of the city. And so I'd like to know how you found yourself there. My wife's family are all from down this way. And so with me being on the road a lot, it made sense to be closer to her, have her, you know, a support system around. And I love it down here, to be honest with you. There was something about LA that always made me
感觉有点边缘化。对，而且这也是一个充满工业气息的城镇，住在一个还有其他事情发生的地方感觉挺不错的，我猜是吧？对，对，那是很大一部分原因。而且这里非常适合步行，有好吃的食物，还有善良的人。这是一个不错的小地方，我很喜欢，对。对。
feel a little bit edgy. Yeah, and it's also like, it's such an industry town and it's nice to live a place where there's other stuff going on, I bet, yeah? Yeah, yeah, that's a big part of it. And it's very walkable, there's good food, nice people. It's a good little spot, I like it, yeah. Yeah.
我们马上回来。现在，回到节目中。这是一个不错的小地方，我很喜欢，对。我们马上回来。现在回到节目中。话说，你们有孩子吗？对，我们有两个男孩，我们有两个男孩。多大了？一个七岁，一个两岁，简直是一团糟。我们昨夜带大儿子去了急诊室，因为他的头裂开了一个口子，缝了钉子。
And we will be right back. And now, back to the show. It's a good little spot, I like it, yeah. And we will be right back. And now back to the show. Now, children, you have? Yes, we've got two boys, we've got two boys. How old? Which is seven and two, which is chaos. We were in A&E last night with my older one getting staples in his head because he cut his head open.
他没事，他没事。男孩子总是会让你不得不去急诊室。威尔，你可以作证，伙计。我有三个男孩，我去过急诊室很多次了。哦，对，对，对。我有两个女孩，只去过一次。只去过一次急诊室。真的吗？
He's fine, he's fine. Boys will take you to the emergency room. Will, you can test to that guy. I have three boys, I've been many times to the emergency. Oh yeah, yeah, yeah. I have two girls, only once. Only once in the emergency room. Are you serious?
我大儿子现在16岁了，有一次他大约11岁的时候，胳膊骨折了，打着石膏，刚拆石膏的那天，他又把它摔断了。什么？不会吧。为什么我不记得这个？那是阿奇吗？对，拜托，你怎么会记得？你连自己写过什么都不知道？
I had my eldest who's 16 now, once when he was about 11, he broke his arm, he had it in a cast, he got it off, the day he got it off, he re-broke it. What? No way. Why don't I remember that? That's Archie? Yeah, well how would you remember, Mike? You don't even know what you wrote?
不管怎样，那是阿奇。他每次是怎么弄断的？每次都是，就是太傻了，跑着跑着，摔倒，绊倒，他以前有一种倾向，喜欢往一个方向跑，但眼睛却看着另一个方向。经常这样。就像经常这样。他其实非常聪明，伙计。
Anyway, it was Archie. How did he do it each time? Just each time, just foolish, just running, falling, tripping, he used to have this sort of proclivity to run one direction but be looking the other direction. Constantly. Like constantly. He's super bright, man.
你会看到他一边跑，往那边去，然后嘴里喊着“啊”，然后就摔倒了。哦，真的吗？对，对，对，不管怎样。不管怎样，所以我去过那儿。所以你现在手忙脚乱的，一个两岁一个七岁，这个年龄差挺好的，对吧？挺不错的，对。对，年龄差挺好的。
You'd see him running, going this way, and going like, ah, and then fall. Oh really? Yeah, yeah, yeah, anyway. Anyway, so I've been there. So you got your hands full, two and seven, that's a good spread, right? That's a nice, yeah. Yeah, that's a good spread, right? That's a nice, yeah.
对，是个挺不错的年龄差。不过，哎呀，我可怜的妻子现在快累死了，他昨天在急诊室，而我大概在上周把前十字韧带撕裂了。不会吧。哦，真的吗？就在上周？对，对。你怎么弄的？
Yeah, that's a good little spread. But yeah, my poor wife at the moment, he was in A&E, I tore my ACL like last week. No. Oh, you did? Just last week? Yeah, yeah. How'd you do that?
打篮球。你看，我们现在真的老了，不适合做这个了。尼克，你比我们年轻得多，但你还是太老了。最让人难过的是这个。这比受伤本身更让人心痛，当时我回来后就开始像“谷歌医学专家”一样搜索。我说，“哦不，怎么回事？巴拉巴拉。”当我发现这是完全撕裂时，我查了一下，
Playing basketball. You see, we're just too old to do it now. Nick, you're considerably younger than us, but you're still too old. This was the really sad thing. This was what hurt more than the injury, was I was back and then I was like Google M.D.ing. I was like, oh no, what's happening? Blah blah. And when I found out it was a full tear of this, I looked it up and
然后那个关于伤情的AI评估说，这种情况最常发生在进行跳跃运动的中年人身上。哦，真的吗？是这样吗？就像，“哎呀，真没必要特意提‘中年’这两个字。”就像把这个甩在我脸上一样。你已经去做过修复手术了吗？还没，没有。哦，真没必要特意提中年，就像把这个甩在我脸上一样。你已经去做过修复手术了吗？还没有，没有，没有。我目前还在做康复治疗，等
and like the A.I. review of the injury was like most frequent in middle aged people who play jumping sports. Oh, really? Is that true? Like, oh, there's no need for the middle age. It's like throwing that at me. Have you already gone in and done the the the repair on it? No, not yet. No, oh, there's no need for the middle aid as I'm throwing that at me. Have you already gone in and done the repair on it? No, not yet, no, no, no. I'm kind of like rehabbing at the moment
等拍完这部电影之后再做。哦，真的吗？所以这是一场大手术。你还能一瘸一拐地走吗？我现在可以走动，哦，现在可以，对，对，对。但如果我做了手术，我想有一段时间就不能动了。
and then we'll do that once. Once you're finished with the film. Yeah. Oh really? Yeah, so it's a big. You can hobble around on it? I can get around, oh right now, yeah, yeah, yeah. But if I did the surgery, I think I couldn't for a while.
但我听说现在这都是门诊手术了。他们就是用一个小软管摄像头伸进去，清理一下就出来了。不，我想对于这个伤，他们得……因为这是一个完全撕裂，我想他们大概是从我的髌骨上切下一块连着骨头的组织，把它用螺丝钉固定上去。然后在你的膝盖骨侧面钻孔。
But I hear that that's just sort of outpatient stuff nowadays. They just like go in there with like a little hose camera and like sweep it up and get out. No, I think for this they have to... Because it's a complete tattoo, I think they like cut out a piece of my patella with the bone and screw that in. And then they drill into the side of your knee.
我不知道。听起来不太妙。不，老实说，听起来挺可怕的。所以，但你现在必须，你得等到大卫·雷奇这部电影拍完。那里面有特技动作。他做特技动作，而你的电影叫《如何抢劫银行》。里面会有很多动作戏。
I don't know. It doesn't sound great. No, it sounds pretty terrible to be honest. So, but now you're going to, this is you got to wait till after the David Leitch thing. That there's stunts in that. He does stunt stuff and you're, it's called how to rob a bank. There's going to be activity in that.
你打算怎么应对？动作戏。对，我会想办法解决的。这就是为什么我目前在做康复治疗。我们要看看在此之前我能恢复得有多强壮。你在《游牧人》里抢银行可真是抢得过瘾。各位，你们一定要去看《游牧人》。那部电影太棒了。
How are you going to do that? Activity. Yeah, I'm going to figure that out. That's why I'm rehabbing at the moment. We'll see how strong I can get beforehand. Now you robbed a hell out of a bank in The Order. Everybody, you gotta see The Order. That movie's so good.
我最近接连拍了好几部抢银行的片子。对。对，太棒了。这部电影在抢银行的桥段上和那部有什么不同？它涉及的范围更广吗？它是现代背景，但我可以说，就我的角色以及他为什么卷入其中而言，它更像是一个罗宾汉式的故事。
I'm on a good bank robbing run. Yeah. Yeah, it was so good. How does this one differ from that as far as the bank robbery stuff? Is it more involved? It's modern, but I would say it's more of a Robin Hood-esque story in terms of my character, why he's gotten into this It's modern, but I would say it's more of a Robin Hood-esque story
就我的角色以及他为什么卷入其中而言，它更像是一个罗宾汉式的故事，以及他如何围绕这个事件为正义事业发起一场革命。那尼尚呢？我觉得你可能还不知道这个，或者还没完全消化，但我敢看看斯高特的屏窗，他肯定已经知道了。尼克要出演《超人》了。我知道，跟我讲讲那个。饰演莱克斯·卢瑟。
in terms of my character, why he's gotten into this, and how he's kind of revolutionizing a movement around it for good causes, essentially. Now what about Nishan? I don't think you know this yet, or haven't really processed it yet, but I bet you Scottie has considering his screensaver. Nick's coming up in Superman. I know, tell me about that. As Lex Luthor.
太棒了！那是七月份上映，对吧？是这样吗？是的，7月11日，对。好吧，那是什么感觉？让人望而生畏吗？你能谈谈这是哪个版本的莱克斯·卢瑟吗？因为他过去有不同的职业背景，对吧？
That's so great! That is released in July, correct? Is that right? Yes, July 11th, yeah. Alright, so what was that? Daunting? Can you talk about what version of Lex Luthor this is? Because he's had different occupations in the past, correct?
是的。对。我是说，通过漫画和电影，有很多不同的版本，关于他到底是什么样的人。詹姆斯·冈恩喜欢把他形容成一个——那是导演，对吧？差不多，是的。在这部电影里，他几乎像是一个巫师，他所研究的科学达到了那种水平。
Yes. Yeah. I mean, there's so many different variations of it through the comics and the films and in terms of what he is. James Gunn likes to describe him almost as a... That's the director, yes? Almost, yes. Almost as a sorcerer in this, the level of science he's working on.
但你知道的，他是一个科技亿万富翁，负责国防。我们开始这个《超人》的故事时，大都会已经是一个高度发展的城市了，有点像是把你直接扔进一个已经完全构想出来的世界和宇宙中，所有这些已经存在了一阵子的角色都在那里，然后你得去赶上他们的进度。现在把反派设定为科技亿万富翁，这很合适，对吧？
But you know, he's a tech billionaire defense. And we start this Superman story, like in an already developed metropolis, kind of you're thrown into a world and universe that's already fully imagined, and all these characters that have been around for a minute, and you kind of catch up with where you're at. It's the appropriate thing nowadays, right,
但这也算顺理成章。你会觉得，这并不生硬……你不会说，什么？你会觉得，对，对，对，就是这样，就是这样。这很符合逻辑。对，这确实显得非常贴切，对吧。对。
to make the villain a tech billionaire. But that kind of lines up. You go like, it's not a straight... You don't go like, what? You go, yeah, yeah, yeah, that's right, that's right. That's not believable. Yeah, it certainly seems very apt, yeah. Yeah.
你在里面有反派造型吗？你的……他传统上不是应该光头吗？非常贴切，对吧。完全光头。是的。那头发重新长出来的过程是怎么样的？因为我听说有些人很担心这个，担心他们的头发再也长不出来了。后来又长出来了。可能没有以前那么浓密、茂盛和美妙了。我不知道。
Did you have a villain look in that? What did you... Isn't he traditionally... He's traditionally been baldheaded, right? Very apt, yeah. Completely clean. Yes. And then what was the grow back process on that? Because I hear some people worry about that, that their hair is never going to come back. It came back. Maybe not as full and lush and wonderful. I don't know.
等等，你必须把头发剃光吗？为了拍一部叫《三个活宝》的电影，我不得不把头剃光了。非常相似。那可真是张照片！他们太疯狂了！抱歉，这是一个内部梗，一点都不好笑。那张照片有多糟糕？他们太疯狂了！抱歉，这是一个内部梗，一点都不好笑。但我不得不把它剃光……这帮当兵的简直跟疯了一样！
Wait, did you have to shave it? I had to shave my head for a movie called The Three Stooges. Very similar. That was a picture! They're so crazy! Sorry, it's an inside thingy that's not funny. How bad was the picture? They're so crazy! Sorry, it's an inside thingy that's not funny. But I had to shave it... These soldiers are some kind of bananas!
这房间里的回声真好。那房间里的混响效果真不错。等等，尼克，你必须……我一天得剃两次头，因为刚剃完就开始长，胡茬就要冒出来了。你必须剃头吗？你头发长得挺快的，对。对，我是说，你一天得剃两次头吗？
It's the presence in that room. That's a good reverb in that room. Wait, Nick, did you have to... I had to shave it twice a day because it would start, right? The stubble would start showing. Did you have to shave it? You've got a lot of growth, yeah. Yeah, I mean, did you have to shave it twice a day?
不，是一天一次，但他们会在头顶喷上一层喷漆。哦，我明白了，我明白了。这总比戴光头头套折腾要好吧？对，我其实没怎么戴过光头头套，但我觉得那感觉就像一整天都戴着游泳帽，又热又闷。你们是在哪里拍摄的？
No, it was once a day, but then they'd kind of spray paint over the top of it. Oh, I see, I see. It was better than a bald cap and doing all that, right? Yeah, I haven't really done the bald cap thing too much, but I feel like it's like we're in a swimming cap throughout the day and it gets all hot and sweaty. And where did you film it?
因为是在国家的哪个部分？肖恩，我们在哪个星球拍的？对。你想去参观一下他们的取景地吗？你在干什么？不，因为我想知道那里热不热。因为当你问一个问题时，我终于明白了。
Because what part of the country? We film a planet, Sean? Yeah. You want to do a tour of their locations? What are you doing? No, because I wanted to know if it was hot or not. Because it was, when you write a question, now I understand.
好吧，好吧，好吧。因为剃了光头？你想知道那里是不是……好吧，因为我的情况是，当我每天都剃光头时，那是在亚特兰大，天气太热了，以至于我回到酒店睡觉时把空调开到最大，我还得在头上戴一顶滑雪帽，因为空调吹在我光秃秃的头皮上实在是太冷了。这家伙根本搞不清状况！你难道就不能把空调调小一点吗，笨蛋？不，不，不。
Okay, so so so. Because of the shaved head? You want to know if it was... Well because my thing is when I shaved my head every single day, it was in Atlanta, it was so hot that when I went into my hotel to sleep I cranked up the AC and I had to wear a ski hat, ski cap on my head because the AC was so cold on my bald head. This guy doesn't know whether he's coming or going! You didn't want to just turn down the AC, Ding Dong? No, no, no.
对，我才不想那么做。不，不。明白了。不管怎样，你想知道他有没有类似的经历？对。跟你经历的那些疯狂事情一样吗？我能感同身受。那可不是自己找罪受。
Yeah, I wouldn't want to do that. No, no. Got it. Anyway, you want to know if he had a similar experience? Yeah. To your fucking lunacy that you were going through? I can relate. It wasn't self-injured.
我们在斯瓦尔巴特群岛拍了一小部分电影。那是在哪？大概靠近北极圈，在——不是自己找罪受。我们在斯瓦尔巴特群岛拍了一小部分电影。那是在哪？大概靠近北极圈，在北极圈里。哦，哇。那里的一个挪威岛屿。所以那里非常冷，而我的头，你知道的，光秃秃的。这就是我想说的。所以会觉得很冷。
We shot a little bit of the film in Svalbard. Where's that? It's kind of near the Arctic Circle, in the't self-induced. We shot a little bit of the film in Svalbard. Where's that? It's kind of near the Arctic Circle, in the Arctic Circle. Oh, wow. Norwegian island up there. And so that was very cold and my head was, you know, naked. That's what I'm saying. And it would get chilly.
这就是我想说的。不，不，不，根本不是你想的那样。他当时是因为冷才戴着他妈的帽子的。而且他在北极圈里。因为他在北极圈里。不是在亚特兰大的欧姆尼酒店。不是在最热的城市……在酒店里。
That's what I'm saying. No, no, no, it's not what you're saying. He was wearing a fucking hat because it was cold. And he was in the Arctic Circle. Because he was in the Arctic Circle. Not the Omni in Atlanta. Not in the hottest city in the... In the hotel.
好吧，不，我拒绝戴帽子。本来帽子是戏服的一部分。但我拒绝了那顶帽子。向正在从公路旅行回来的老鹰队球员打招呼。干得漂亮，伙计们。有人觉得冷吗？抱歉，迪克。
Well, no, I refused the hat. There was a hat as part of the costume. But I said no to the hat. Saying hi to the Hawks players as they were coming back from a road trip. Great win, fellas. Anyone cold? Sorry, Dick.
抱歉，尼克。我们今天太散漫了。我们真的很散漫。现在，让我们从头说起。让我们从头说起。我本想说同样的话，一路说回来。威尔，你想从《关于一个男孩》开始聊起吗，威尔？你的问题是从那部电影来的吗？我只是想知道这一切是怎么开始的。
Sorry, Nick. We're pretty sloppy today. We are very sloppy. Now, let's go all the way back. Let's go all the way back. I was going to say the same thing all the way going. Will, would you like to start it about a boy, Will? Is that where your question is coming from? I just want to know how it all started.
尼克，你是怎么成为现在的你的？你把工作做得这么好。这一切是怎么……对，对。你演艺生涯的起点是什么？哪一天你醒来然后心想，哦，今天我想成为一名演员？对。对。
Nick, how did you become you? You're so good at what you do. How did that all... Yeah, yeah. What was the beginning of your journey? What was the day that you woke up and went, oh, today I want to be an actor? Yeah. Yeah.
我有，嗯，我很幸运。我爸妈没有从事这个行业，但我哥哥姐姐，我哥哥非常喜欢表演，我姐姐则做了很多唱歌跳所以它有点——现在他们恨死你了。
There's, well, I was lucky. My mom and dad weren't involved in a business, but my older brother and sister, my older brother really loved acting, and my older sister did a lot of singing and dancing, and was very talented with that as well. So it kind of- And now they hate you.
现在他们痛恨我。不，所以那是他们的爱好和热情，而作为一个老三，我最终只是觉得，好吧，你最后总是会去上舞蹈课或者参加戏剧演出之类的，你不知不觉就被拖进去了。所以在某种程度上，这就像是家庭爱好，后来通过他们的精湛技艺，我很幸运地找到了一经纪人，然后就一直坚持演下去了。
And now they detest me. No, so that was their hobby and passion and it kind of, being the third sibling, I kind of just ended up being like, all right, you end up in dance classes or in theater shows and whatever, you kind of just get dragged. So it was kind of like the family hobby in some ways that then through them being skilled managed to get lucky and get an agent and then kind of keep doing it.
他们现在还在演吗？他们还在演吗？目前没有，没有。我小妹还在电影行业工作。她担任副导演（AD），但我哥哥是个法医化学家，我大姐教跳舞什么的。等等，你最小的妹妹是副导演？对。
Are they still doing it. Are they still doing it? Not at the moment, no. My little sister still works in film. She works as an AD, but my brother's a forensic chemist and my older sister teaches dancing and stuff. Wait, your youngest is an AD? Yeah.
太棒了。那是片场最难的工作，第一副导演。我觉得除了第一摄影助理（AC）就是这个了。对，统筹工作可能非常困难，因为你得经常叫大家离开房车。对，没错。有些人就是不想离开。
That's awesome. That's the hardest job on the set, first AD. That and first AC, I think. Yeah, the base running can be very difficult because you have to tell people to get out of their trailers a lot. Yeah, exactly. And some people don't want to leave.
真诱人。肖恩，你想跟特雷西解释一下副导演部门吗，还是说这太长了？当然。就是助理导演，对吧？对，第一副导演。等等，稍等。你想从解释这个缩写开始吗？
Inviting. Sean, do you want to explain the AD department to Tracy or is that too long? Sure. It's the assistant director, right? Yeah, first AD. Wait, hang on. You want to start with clarifying what the acronym is?
不，我的意思是，你刚才说，你不是AC。我不知道AC是什么。助理摄影师。摄影。焦点员。不，但是助理，第一助理导演他们的工作，然后是第二助理导演以及第二副导演，这些人实际上是在运作电影的骨架，可以说是这样。他们让列车按时运行。
No, but I meant like, you you said, you're not AC. I don't know what AC is. Assistant camera. Camera. Focus below. No, but the assistant, first assistant director in their job and then the people who were for then the second and the second second, those people are the people who, in effect, run the skeleton of the film, as it were. They keep the trains running on time.
他们做了所有的事情。他们的工作太繁重了。对，从他们醒来的那一秒起就没停过。极其重要。对。太好了。所以，《关于一个男孩》。在我们的赞助商广告之后，你觉得呢？
They do all the things. their jobs are so immense. Yeah, they don't stop from the second they wake up. Couldn't be more important. Yeah. All right. Great. So, About A Boy. By a word from our sponsor, do you think?
不。我们只是想给广告留一点小空隙。话说回来，《关于一个男孩》是你演的第一部作品，还是第一部真正把你推向公众视野的作品？对，那算是一个突破吧。我在英国之前也演过一些东西，但对，那是让我觉得，
No. We just want to leave a little break for the commercial. Now, was About A Boy the first project that you did or was it the first thing that really kind of launched you into public viewing? Yeah, that was kind of a breakthrough, I guess. I'd been in a few things before in England, but yeah, that was the one that was like,
哦，感觉完全不一样了。你的第一份专业工作是什么？第一份专业工作，我想我三四岁的时候演过一出舞台剧，感觉完全不一样，对。我觉得挺简单的。他们说，我就坐在桌子底下假装吃蛋糕。这我行。我行。好吧，好吧，肖恩。肖恩现在就是这么干的，因为他不想让任何人知道他在吃糖。
oh, this feels like we're different. What was your first professional job? First professional job, I think I did a play when I was like three or four, We're different, yeah. It was very easy, I thought. They were like, I will sit under this table and pretend to eat cake. I can do that. I can do that. All right, all right, Sean. That's how Sean does it now, because he doesn't want anybody to know he's eating sugar.
而且我甚至都没去试镜。那么，那部剧，你11岁时发生了这件事，我想那是一次有趣的经历，然后电影上映了，成了一个大热门。从一个普通小孩转变成这样，有什么适应过程吗？你的朋友们开始问你，你身上发生什么事了吗？对，因为《关于一个男孩》太火了。对。
And I'm not even auditioning. Now, what did that, so you're 11 and this thing happens and I imagine it was a fun experience and then it comes out and it's kind of a big hit. And what was the adjustment from being just a kid to like, did your friends start to say, what's going on with you? Yeah, because that about a boy was so huge. Yeah.
而且我甚至都没有去试镜。那么，这是怎么回事，你11岁时发生了这件事，我想那是一段有趣的经历，然后电影上映了，成了一个挺大的热门。从一个普通孩子转变成这样，需要怎样的适应过程？你的朋友们开始问你，你到底怎么了？是的，因为《单亲插班生》太火了。是的。
Oh, this is getting into a bit of a therapy session here now. Yeah, just lay down if you need to. Mm-hmm. Yeah, I suppose that was a bit weird because it was, I don't know, fairly recognizable for a little weird because it was a fair, I don't know, fairly recognizable for a little bit through it. But luckily it's also one of those things where also, it's like kids don't care.
哦，这听起来有点像在做心理治疗了。对，如果你需要的话就躺下吧。嗯。对，我想这有点奇怪，因为怎么说呢，有一段时间它其实挺容易被认出来的。不过幸运的是，这也是那种——就像小孩子根本不在乎一样。
They care and then they don't care and everything passes so quickly that it's one of those things where you just get on with life. You're starting to get a bunch of attention at school and some of the boys might not like that right Jealous, you know what most people were pretty nice. Most people were pretty nice. Yeah. Yeah, it was it was kind of I'm projecting There's but it makes you self-conscious of yourself. I suppose more than anything else you like of course, right? Right, right imagine at that age. Yeah feeling like feeling like because some people are mentioning it and some people are looking at you And then you feel like is everybody looking and it would make you very self-conscious And if you're young especially in those adolescent years, which are tough enough as it is
他们会在意一会儿，然后又不在乎了，一切都过去得那么快，以至于你只需继续过你的人生就行了。你在学校开始受到很多关注，有些男生可能不太喜欢那样，对吧？嫉妒呗，你知道吗，其实大部分人都挺好的。大部分人都挺好的。对。对，那感觉有点……我在投射。不过比起其他任何事情，这会让你对自己的意识变得更加敏感，对吧？对，对，想象一下在那个年纪。对，那种感觉，就因为有些人在提这事，有些人看着你，然后你会觉得是不是所有人都在看着你，这会让你变得非常在意自己的形象。如果你还年轻，特别是在那些青春期阶段，本来就已经够难熬的了。
Mm-hmm. It must be a it must be quite tricky. Really. Yeah, you become like I suppose Yeah, even more of a version of like so yeah, just being like self-aware in-aware in a horrible way, which you probably don't want. Were you like, this was a fun hobby, a good reason to miss class, or were you thinking, great, I've got a nice jump start on my career? Did you decide this is what I'm going to do the rest of my life at that point? No, because everyone talks about how child actors often fall apart and fail and how it doesn't work out for them. So you're aware of that conversation, so you're kind of like, there's a good chance. Everyone talks about how child actors often fall apart and fail
嗯。那一定……那真的相当棘手。对，你会变得，我想是的，甚至会进入一种——嗯，就是以一种糟糕的方式对自己有了过多的审视，而这大概是你并不想要的。你当时觉得这只是个有趣的爱好、一个翘课的好借口呢，还是在想：“太好了，我的职业生涯有了一个不错的起步”？那时候你有没有决定这就是你余生要去做的事？没有，因为每个人都在讨论童星往往是如何崩溃、失败的，以及这条路对他们来说是如何行不通的。所以你是知道这种舆论的，你心里就会想，很有可能……每个人都在讨论童星往往是如何崩溃、失败的
and how it doesn't work out for them. In the back of my mind I was like, I'd like to carry on doing this, but also I was kind of reserved about it a little bit. You're not unfamiliar with this sensation? Yeah, so did you, like me, when it came time to finish high school and now it's the decision about going on and going into college and actually studying up on an industry or an occupation, what was that decision like?
以及这条路对他们来说是如何行不通的。我心底的想法是，我挺想继续做下去的，但同时我对这件事也多少保持着保留的态度。你对这种感觉并不陌生吧？对，所以你是不是也像我一样，到了要高中毕业的时候，面临着要不要继续上大学、去真正深入学习某个行业或职业的抉择，当时那个决定是怎样的？
You had some momentum going at that moment. Did you make a decision like screw it, I'm all in? At that moment I was lucky. I did a TV show in England called Skins. moment did you make a decision like screw it I'm all in? focusing on school than half focusing on work and I wasn't really fully into either. So I was like, you know what, I'm just going to commit and then give the acting a try and see how it goes and if I need it, I can come back to school.
那时候你正顺风顺水。你有没有做出那种“管他呢，我豁出去了”的决定？那一刻我很幸运。我在英国拍了一档叫《皮囊》的电视剧。那个时候你有没有做出那种“管他呢，我豁出去了”的决定？一半心思放在学校，一半心思放在工作上，结果两边都没法全心投入。所以我当时就想，你知道吗，我索性就全身心投入，然后去尝试一下演戏，看看到时候情况怎么样；如果实在不行，我随时可以再回学校。
Yeah. And you thought maybe I'd give it three, four years, something like that. Because that's like, it's a real roll of the dice, right? Because you'd have to go back into college and yeah, it's stressful. Yeah, and there wasn't anything that I was particularly good at either.
对。而且你当时想的是，或许我可以试个三四年，诸如此类。因为这就好比是真正的孤注一掷，对吧？因为你还得重新回大学去……是的，这压力很大。对，而且也没有什么是我特别擅长的。
What do you think you would have done if you had to do something different? I really have no idea because I'm not good at anything. I say the same thing, I'm not joking. I always say I'm not good at anything. What would you have liked to have done if you couldn't have acted? Oh, just be a race car driver. For real. Or a rock star. F1?
如果你必须做点别的，你觉得你会做什么？我真的完全不知道，因为我什么都不擅长。我也这么说，我不是在开玩笑。我总是说我什么都不擅长。如果你不能演戏了，你最想做什么？哦，去当个赛车手。真的。或者摇滚巨星。F1吗？
Or a writer or something. Yeah, yeah, yeah. I enjoy watching F1. But I don't know, I didn't really have a backup. But I think the one thing that I like, the eclectic mix that acting allows you to do, kind of be a jack of all trades. I don't think I excel at anything particularly, but I can kind of dibble dabble a little bit in lots of things. You get to do everything, which you certainly have done.
或者当个作家什么的。对，对，对。我很喜欢看F1。不过我不知道，我真的没有什么备选方案。但我认为我喜欢的一点是，表演这种工作能让你体验各种各样杂七杂八的东西，算是个全能多面手吧。我不觉得自己有什么特别精通的，但各种领域我都能稍微涉猎和尝试一下。你几乎什么都能体验到，而你也确实做到了。
I mean, the variance of projects that you do and filmmakers that you work with, I mean, it's... Yeah, a lot of people chase fame and other people chase the work. And I feel it. No. No, no, just say it again, because I've got a blank T-shirt I was looking to fill.
我是说，你参与的项目和合作的电影人们，风格跨度非常大，我是说，这……对，很多人追逐名利，而另一些人则是为了工作本身。我懂的。不。不，不，你再说一遍，因为我正想找一件空白的T恤把这句印上去呢。
And Nick, you always seem like you chase fame. No, no, just say it again, because I've got a blank t-shirt I was looking to fill. Ha. I mean I can play piano. Were you drawn to anything like college? I mean I thought I was going to be a conductor and I thought I was going to compose film scores. Oh that's right. JB what about you? What would you, sorry, what would you do if you could? The same thing you asked Nick. What would you do if you could?
尼克，你总是给人一种你在追逐名利的感觉。不，不，不，你再说一遍，因为我正想找一件空白的T恤把这句印上去。哈哈。我是说我会弹钢琴。你以前对上大学之类的有什么向往吗？我是说，我曾以为自己会成为一名指挥家，我以为我会去创作电影配乐。哦，对哦。JB，你呢？你会，抱歉，如果你可以的话，你会做什么？就像你问尼克的那样。如果你可以的话，你会做什么？
I wanted to, I wanted to be an architect. I wanted to like design residential homes. Oh wow, you have to draw really well. And I can't really draw draw, I just like architecture. Yeah, I do too. I would have gone into that. I would have had to have a partner that knew the math. But anything, but any answer that you play out,
我曾想，我曾想成为一名建筑师。我想设计住宅。哦，哇，你得画画非常好才行。我其实并不太会画画，我只是喜欢建筑。对，我也是。我会选择那一行。不过我得找一个懂数学的合伙人。但是不管你脑海里构思的是什么答案，
like architect or whatever, then you go, God, I have to go to school, and then I have to read and draw and everything. Like it's so, there's so much work involved where acting feels just like you're playing. Like you're lucky enough to. But the trade off with that is that you've got no, you've got no guarantee of employment.
比如建筑师什么的，然后你就会想：“天哪，我得去上学，还得看书、画画以及做各种事情。”这里面涉及的工作量太巨大了，而演戏给人的感觉就像是在玩耍。就像你有幸能去……但与之相伴的代价是，你没有任何就业保障。
I know, that's true. I would have been a bartender at a club bed. Just asking for beads. Just fuck it, just fuck it. Just flip flops all the time and just fuck it. Flit and cigarettes. Whatever, whatever. Just ride it out.
我知道，这是真的。我大概会去某家俱乐部当个酒保吧。只要管要小费就行。去他妈的，管他呢。整天穿着人字拖，管他呢。到处晃荡，抽着烟。随便啦，随便啦。就这么混过去吧。
Yeah. We'll be right back. And back to the show. But seriously, Nick, how are you picking your jobs? It seems like you're looking at kind of who's in it, who's directing it, kind of what's the quality of it, as opposed to what's the star-making potential of it? No, no, no, I'm chasing fame and money.
好。我们马上回来。欢迎回到节目中。但说真的，尼克，你究竟是怎么挑选工作的？看起来你更看重谁参演、谁执导，以及作品的质量本身，而不是它有多大的成名潜力？不，不，不，我在追逐名利和金钱。
No, you're not. Like a rabid animal, but I just can't achieve to. I'll bet you get a bunch of that low-hanging fruit pass right underneath your nose and you've been very disciplined. Yeah. I try to be, it's one of those where, yeah, I feel like I just want to do good work and one of those where I feel like
不，你才没有。像个疯狗一样，但我就是达不到那种程度。我敢说，很多唾手可得的好机会从你鼻子底下溜走，而你一直都非常自律。对。我尽量吧，这工作就是这样，对，我觉得我只是想做好作品，然后那种感觉就是……
I just want to do good work and have like, when I'm sitting in my rocking chair in 50 years time, looking back, I'm like, oh yeah, you tried to really create special things each time. Are there any roles, without naming names, are there any roles that you turned down that you went, I wish I had done it. You were having fun. You know what, I think for the first time there was maybe one where the person got nominated for an Oscar. Mm-hmm. And I was like, ooh. Oh, really?
我只想拍出好作品，并且在50年后的某一天，当我坐在摇椅上回首往事时，会觉得：“哦，对啊，你每次都尝试过去创造一些特别的东西。”有没有哪个角色——不提具体名字——有没有哪个角色是你曾拒绝过，后来却心想：“我真希望当时接了”？你当时正玩得开心呢。你知道吗，我觉得破天荒头一次，还真有这么一个角色，那个演员后来获得了奥斯卡提名。嗯。然后我就想：哦。哦，真的吗？
Now, did they play the part the way that you would have? Oh, much better, much better. That's always the thing. Whenever there's a role that you don't get or that someone else does or whatever, there's always a thing where you watch it and you're like, oh yeah, I know, I see. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
那么，他们演这个角色的方式，和你设想的一样吗？哦，好得多，好得多。事情总是这样。每当有你没拿到或者被别人演了的角色，无论如何，你总是会在观看的时候心想：“哦，对，我懂，我明白。”对，对，对。
It's different. And it's very classy that you're like, oh yeah, I know, I see. It's different. And it's very classy that you're not mentioning what that is too. I think some actors that they mention, and then the person that feels like shit is the person who actually did the part. Because it's like, oh, so I was second. Right.
感觉不一样。而且你没有说出那部作品是什么，这显得你非常有风度。感觉不一样。而且你没有说出那部作品是什么，这显得你非常有风度。我觉得有些演员会说出来，然后觉得最不是滋味的人其实是那个真正演了该角色的人。因为那感觉就像是：“哦，原来我是备选第二名。”没错。
Right, right, right. Right, right, right. But there's always that, you know, whatever, there's always a list that goes, like the turnover of a project, I'm sure you guys see it all the time when it's like, oh, this script's been around for a minute, it was this person for a while, then it's this person,
对，对，对。对，对，对。但总是会有那种情况，不管怎样，总有一个候选名单，也就是项目的演员变动，我确信你们俩经常能看到这种情况，比如：“哦，这个剧本流传了好一阵子了，一开始定的是这个人，后来又换成了那个人。”
and it's kind of like, yeah. I'm just finishing up one of those. Pedro Pascal was set to do the Barnum plan. Anyway, what do you think about- God, he would have been great. I know, right? No, I'm sorry, I'm just imagining him, and he's so good.
情况差不多就是这样。我刚好在收尾这样一个项目。原本是定由佩德罗·帕斯卡来演《巴纳姆计划》的。不管怎样，你觉得——天哪，他本可以演得很棒。我懂，对吧？不，对不起，我只是在脑海里想象了一下，他真的是太棒了。
It would have been good. Now, what about doing X-Men, Scotty just should just grab the ceiling. That was a lot. I would. So doing doing X-Men or like Mad Max or Superman like you are you are sneaking in some big commercial films as well. That work process on that is, you're only doing like a half a page a day, and it's, right, the apparatus is just huge.
那肯定会很棒。那么，去演《X战警》呢？斯科蒂简直应该直接去抓天花板了。那可真是一大摊事。我愿意。所以去演《X战警》或者《疯狂的麦克斯》或者《超人》之类的，你其实也在悄悄接演一些商业大片。那类电影的工作流程是，你一天可能只拍半页剧本，而且，没错，整个制作机器实在是太庞大了。
Do you like doing that, or do you prefer doing the smaller films where you're really chugging along and you gotta do a bunch of pages a day, and it's a lot of, it's more acting than it is sort of stunts and effects and things like that? It's different. I really enjoy the stunt process of those things, a bunch of pages a day and it's more acting for everyone to start up their engines immediately thinking about all the dust and how far base camp is from set. Yeah, yeah, yeah. You know, what kind of, is it like,
你喜欢那样的工作方式吗？还是说你更喜欢小成本电影，那种你必须快马加鞭、一天得拍一大堆剧本页数的节奏？那种情况下，更多的是在演戏，而不是搞什么特技和特效之类的东西。感觉不一样。我其实很喜欢那些大片里的特技拍摄过程，一天拍很多页剧本，而且那更需要每个人一开机就立刻进入状态，同时还得考虑所有的尘土，以及大本营距离片场到底有多远。对，对，对。你知道，那种感觉就像是……
you're gonna have an umbrella near my chair because it's probably just really hot. It is though, but to Jason's question, the comfort level of doing like an indie, like a super small budget compared to when you're used to doing bigger films like that, you have to adjust your expectations about how the day's gonna go in terms of comfort, right?
“我的椅子旁边能放把伞吗，因为这里可能真的很热。”确实是这样。不过顺着杰森的问题来说，相比于你习惯的那种大制作电影，拍独立电影——那种超级小成本制作——在舒适度上的心理落差，你得调整自己对一天下来的舒适度会有怎样的心理预期，对吧？
It's not cushy on the outs in these, right? It's not, yeah. It's bad. It's bad on the indies. Boy, not a question in there. No. Two hosts and not one question. Now, how do you like the whole press part of it? Like doing crap like this, because when you do those bigger films
独立电影的外在条件可一点都不优渥，对吧？确实不优渥，对。条件很差。独立电影的条件就是很差。天哪，里面居然一个问题都没有。没有。两个主持人，连一个问题都提不出来。话说回来，你有多喜欢整个宣传环节？比如做这种破事，因为当你拍那些大片时……
and Superman's starting to come out. Oh, yeah, I was just thinking about you saying July 11th, you know the date, obviously, and it's something you worked on, but it's like this is the lead up, I mean, you've got a long road ahead of you, not to make it too daunting, I'm sorry. But you know that.
而且《超人》马上就要上映了。哦，对，我刚才还在想你说7月11日，你当然知道具体的日期，这是你倾注了心血的作品，但这意味着接下来将是一段造势期，我是说，你前面还有很长的一段路要走，我这么说并不是想吓唬你，抱歉。但你心里有数。
Yeah, those films, so listeners, so you do these big films, they make you fly around, not make you, not sound like we're complaining, but you do, it is very robust, the whole thing, all the chat and giggle stuff you gotta do. How do you like doing that? You know what, I've tried to flip my thinking on it in like the last year or a bit or something,
对，那些电影——听众朋友们，当你们去拍这些大片时，他们会让你到处飞——并不是“让你”，听起来好像我们在抱怨一样，但确实如此，整个流程非常繁重，所有那些你必须应付的访谈和寒暄。你喜欢做这些吗？你知道吗，在过去一年左右的时间里，我试着彻底转变了对这件事的想法。
so where I was like, I used to kind of, not dread it in the last year or a bit or something. I used to kind of not dread it. There was part of me that was like, oh, it's quite fun. But I guess that slight introvert part of me was like, I don't know about... And then I realized I've got to perform and play the game better of what it is. You are ultimately a salesman at that point. And I think somebody said to me a long time, they don't pay you to do the movie, they pay you to promote it. Right.
以前我会有那种……不能说是畏惧，但在过去一年左右的时间里，我不再那么抗拒了。我内心深处其实觉得，哦，其实还挺好玩的。但我想我身上那种轻微的内向特质会让我觉得：我不知道……后来我意识到，我必须去表演，把这个游戏玩得更好，发挥出它应有的效果。说到底，在那一刻你就是一个推销员。我想很久以前有人对我说过，他们付钱不是让你去拍电影的，而是付钱让你去宣传电影的。没错。
And so when you look at it that way, you go like, okay, this is a big part of the job right now. Yeah, so I've got to be a better salesman. Yeah. Well, but as you said it, and I've been accused of this as well, and I think they're right, of being an introvert. I don't, this is not comfortable for me.
所以当你从这个角度来看待它时，你就会想：好吧，这现在是工作很大的一部分。没错，所以我得当一个更好的推销员。没错。不过，正如你所说的那样——我也曾被这样指责过，而且我觉得他们说得对——我是一个内向的人。我……这对我来说并不自在。
I don't want to say that. You're not an introvert. You're boring, this is not comfortable for me. Chide away. I don't want to say that. You're not an introvert. You're boring. Like, you know what I mean? Like I think there's a distinction there. That's what my fear is. I'm like, I'm boring.
我可不想这么说。你才不是内向呢。你只是很无聊，这对我来说并不自在。尽管数落吧。我可不想这么说。你才不是内向呢。你只是很无聊。就像，你知道我的意思吗？我觉得这两者是有区别的。这就是我所恐惧的。我会想：我很无聊。
I just want to stay at home. I want to go and do my acting. I hope people like it. And then like, that's kind of it. Yeah, but there's like... It is effortful. It is effortful. Yeah, but yeah, there's a certain ham ham gene a healthy ham gene that I don't well
我只想待在家里。我只想去演我的戏。我希望大家会喜欢。然后，差不多就那样了。对，但这里面有……这确实需要付出心力。这确实需要付出心力。对，但，对，有一种某种程度上的“爱出风头基因”——一种健康的爱出风头基因——而我并没有……
You feel like you're bragging is part of the problem, right? That and or also just like demanding attention even just and I've talked about it before making a toast I just cringe myself out standing up and and demanding attention You know what? I was thinking about you in the flipping and doing the toast and stuff and we had our friend's birthday Recently a month ago and you guys went and I kind of go because of work and I was thinking about you in the flipping and doing the toast and stuff, and we had our friend's birthday recently a month ago, and you guys went and I kind of go because of work, and I was thinking about the toast, and I remember I wrote that toast for,
你会觉得自己是在自吹自擂，这才是问题所在，对吧？不仅如此，还有那种渴望获得关注的感觉，哪怕只是——我以前也谈过这个——在发表祝酒辞时，光是站起来并要求所有人注意自己，我都尴尬得直起鸡皮疙瘩。你知道吗？我当时在想你举杯祝酒之类的事情，我们一个朋友的生日就在不久前，一个月前，你们都去了，而我因为工作没去，当时我就在想那个祝酒辞，我记得我还专门为那个祝酒辞写过……
I still wrote it to have, and Bradley delivered it while, even though it ain't go. Yeah, it was hilarious. We haven't even talked about that, right? In the toast, I made Bradley go, he does this whole thing, it was for Robert's birthday for Downey, and then I said, and Jason Bateman, I said, Jason, would you please stand up?
我还把它写下来了，结果布莱德利把它念了出来，虽然效果……对，太搞笑了。我们甚至都还没聊过这个呢，对吧？在祝酒辞里，我让布莱德利说——他做了一整套动作，那是为罗伯特·唐尼过的生日——然后我说：“杰森·贝特曼，杰森，请你站起来好吗？”
So Bradley's reading and he says, Jason, would you please stand up? Jason stands up and then Bradley reads, look at this, look at this monkey, I can make him do anything I want, I'm not even here. Anyway. But the. The roof died, it was very close.
于是布莱德利照着念道：“杰森，请你站起来好吗？”杰森站了起来，然后布莱德利继续念：“看看这个，看看这只猴子，我能让他做任何我想让他做的事，甚至我都不用在场。”不管怎样。但是这个……
But here's the flip, JB, which is, and it kind of goes along the lines of you're being paid to do it, is making a toast is it's not about you. Think about it. It's for the other person. So you're making it about you, and it shouldn't be. You're doing it, so I don't necessarily want to go and do it,
全场都笑翻了，气氛简直太棒了。但关键在于，JB，换个角度来看——这其实和你刚才说的“你拿钱办事”相呼应——发表祝酒辞这事，其实根本不是关于你自己的。想想看。这是为了另一个人。所以如果你把它变成关于你自己的事，那就错了。你做这件事是因为……其实我并不一定非得去，
and I don't want to make a speech at somebody's birthday, even though it seems like I do or I want the attention. You're doing it for that person because they want it. And if you look at it through that lens, it's much easier. That's a good point. Yeah, there was like a really interesting thing I was reading the other week, and I'm butchering it completely,
我也不想在别人的生日上发表讲话，尽管看起来好像我很乐意或者我很想博取关注。你做这件事是为了那个人，因为他们希望如此。如果你通过这个视角来看待它，事情就会简单得多。这倒是个好观点。对啊，我前几天读到过一篇非常有趣的文章——虽然我可能完全复述不好，
but what you said there was like being introverted is like a self-centered thing in many ways, and when you're kind of bold in an interaction, instantly it puts the other person at ease. Yeah. And I've got friends who I see do it all the time, when they'll meet someone for the first time and they'll instantly break the ice so brilliantly and do these things where you're like,
但你刚才说的那种感觉，就像内向在很多时候其实是一种以自我为中心的表现，而当你在社交互动中表现得大方时，会立刻让对方感到放松。没错。我有一些朋友，我经常看到他们这样做，当他们第一次遇到某人时，他们能瞬间把气氛活跃得非常精彩，做出那些让你感叹的事情：
oh wow, you can just see how. Well, because it's the work for, somebody told me a long time ago, you're not allowed to be shy after nine years old. Because that just means you just don't want to do the work. And I will say this, I'm not saying that, JB, that you're not a kind, and I don't think that you're self-centered. I think that it's much more,
“哦，哇，你能看出他是怎么做到的。”好吧，因为这就是工作。很久以前有人告诉我，你过了九岁之后就再也没有资格害羞了。因为那只意味着你根本不想去付出努力。而且我要说的是，JB，我并不是说你不是个善良的人，我也不认为你是以自我为中心。我觉得更多的是……
you look at a guy like Kimmel. Kimmel goes out of his way, and he does stuff, and he hosts stuff, and he gives toast, and he does it, I mean, endlessly. Work. Endlessly. And he does it because he's very open-hearted about it,
你看吉米尔那样的家伙。吉米尔总是竭尽全力，他包揽各种事，他主持各种节目，他发表祝酒辞，他一直在做这些，我是说，没完没了。工作。没完没了。他之所以这么做，是因为他对人充满热情，
and he understands that it's important to the other person to do it. Yeah, yeah. Right? Yeah, I love that. If I think about it that way, I would do it much more. Yeah, yeah, yeah. You're right.
并且他懂得这对另一个人来说很重要，所以他才去做。对，对。对吧？对，我太喜欢这个观点了。如果我换这个角度去想，我会更愿意去做的。对，对，对。你说得对。
That feels good. Thank God. 56. That's why I've got your eulogy written right here. It's ready? I just finished it today. Well, I talked to your doctor. You're ready to go?
感觉好多了。谢天谢地。56岁。这就是为什么我把你的悼词都写好了，就放在这儿。已经写好了？我今天刚写完。对了，我跟你医生聊过了。你准备好上路了吗？
I talked to him, hey, side zoom after this? Is that cool? Just to go over it. All right, I'd like to go back to Lex Luthor. Because this is just a major movie that's coming out. I know, I know. I love Superman. Did you have a voice for him? Or is it your regular voice?
我跟他聊过，嘿，等下开个会后会怎么样？可以吗？就为了过一遍这个。好了，我想把话题转回莱克斯·卢瑟身上。因为这可是一部即将上映的大制作电影。我知道，我知道。我太喜欢超人了。你为他设计了一种特殊的嗓音吗？还是用你平时的声音？
Or did you... I'm doing an American accent. I did a voice, yeah. Okay, good. I love that. I worked with an opera coach a little bit on... Oh, really? Which sounds like then the voice is going to be so different. But I was just trying to place the voice differently
还是说你……我用的是美国口音。我确实设计了一种嗓音，对。好的，太棒了。我跟一位歌剧声乐教练合作了一段时间，为了……哦，真的吗？听上去这声音最后会变得非常不同。不过我当时只是想把发声位置调整到不同于我平时说话的地方。
to where my voice is. Yeah, Yeah, I get it. That's cool I like like sort of like the top of your head type thing or something like that You mean I'm trying to get more from my stomach I suppose because sometimes particularly when you're then doing an accent and say becomes Because you're trying to change everything in your mouth and throat in terms of how you're saying the sounds Yeah, it can become placed there a little bit differently and stuff. I don't know. Yeah, yeah.
对，对，我懂。这很酷，我喜欢那种类似于从头顶发声的感觉之类的小把戏。你是说我想要更多地调动我的腹部发声，我想是的，因为有时候，特别是当你同时还要说某种口音时，比方说，当它变成……因为你正试图改变口腔和喉咙里发音的所有方式，
Oh, wow. Yeah. How do you like doing the American accent? Is it easy to you? Yeah, I was going to just ask that. I wouldn't say it's easy because then when I do a bad one, everyone will be like, hmm, not that easy. No, no, no.
所以发声位置确实会稍微变得有点不同，诸如此类。我不知道。对，对。哦，哇。对。你觉得说美国口音感觉怎么样？对你来说容易吗？对啊，我正想问这个。我不会说这很容易，因为一旦我演砸了，每个人都会说：“嗯，看来没那么容易嘛。”不，不，不。
Smart. Is it comfortable? How about that? It gets comfortable. Is the, that's the aim whenever you, like I'm just starting to work on this new accent for this new thing and it's kind of, it's an American accent but it's different to what I've done before
聪明。舒服吗？换个问法呢？慢慢会变得舒服的。这就是你每次——比如我正开始为一样新东西练习一种新口音时，它的目标所在。这是一种美国口音，但跟我以前演过的有所不同，
so then instantly it becomes like, in the moment it still sounds alien in my head, you know? It's like, ugh, and then hopefully with enough repetition by the time we get to shooting, it'll feel like something that I can be like, okay. All right, now are you just working on the material that you've got to work on for the film? Are you trying to inhabit it sort of in a day to day when you're doing the dishes, et cetera,
所以它立刻就会带来一种感觉：在当下那一刻，在我的脑海里它听起来仍然像是外星人的语言，你知道吗？就觉得：呃。然后希望通过足够的重复，等到我们开拍的时候，它就会变成一种让我觉得“行，没问题”的状态。好了，那你现在是在专门练习电影里的台词素材呢？还是说你在日常生活中也试着去沉浸其中，比如洗碗的时候等等，
playing with the kids, trying to get those American cadences, et cetera? Uh-oh. Nice work, Will. Did I frozen him out? Yeah, you just absolutely killed him. Let's take a quick little look-see here. Can you guys hear me? Yes, there you are.
陪孩子们玩耍的时候，努力去寻找那些美国口音的语调，等等？噢哦。干得漂亮，威尔。我是把他给卡掉线了吗？对，你把他彻底搞死了。我们来看一小段画面。你们能听到我说话吗？可以，你在这儿呢。
Yes, sorry, I don't know what happened. Here he comes in video. I'm sweating now. Nick, this is going to be seamless. My question was, do you do the accent all day? Like around kids and stuff. Do you just do it for the material that you're working on or do you try to do it all day? Or do you try to do it and incorporate it into your day-to-day
对，抱歉，我不知道发生了什么。他视频连线进来了。我现在直冒汗。尼克，这下无缝衔接了。我的问题是，你整天都用那种口音说话吗？比如在孩子们周围什么的。你是只在练习台词时用，还是整天都用？或者你会在日常生活中也尝试融入这种口音，
and when you're doing the dishes and playing with the kids? It depends on how long I'm doing the character and stuff. I normally stay in it throughout the day, film. I like, in the morning warm up and like get into it and then try and stay in it. Yeah. And then like at the end of the day I'll go home and I won't talk in it. Do you ever do it around your kids and your kids are like, well dad, what do you, I don't understand you. Occasionally I'll be like, because I sometimes record. Hey Will, have you played golf since you've been done with the movie?
比如在洗碗和陪孩子玩的时候？这取决于我要饰演这个角色多久。拍电影期间，我通常一整天都保持在这个状态里。我喜欢在早晨热身并进入状态，然后尽量保持住。对。然后在一天结束时我会回家，就不会再用那种口音说话了。你在孩子们面前用过这种口音吗，然后他们会问：“爸爸，你在干什么，我听不懂你在说什么”？偶尔我会这样，因为我有时会录音……嘿，威尔，你演完这部电影后打过高尔夫球吗？
I went to the range yesterday. Boy, I figured something out. Oh, did you? And we have Nick with us here. Check, check. Here we go. He's back. Nick Holt?
我昨天去练习场了。天哪，我琢磨出一些门道来。哦，是吗？我们这儿有尼克。测试，测试。我们开始了。他又回来了。尼克·霍尔特？
Yes. There he is. Nick, do you play the golf? Do you play golf at all? I do play the golf. Not very well. Because we were talking about golf during the intermission there. So you're no... Do you all're dual play. We do Sean does not Sean can drive
对。他来了。尼克，你打高尔夫球吗？你平时打高尔夫球吗？我确实打高尔夫球。打得不是很好。因为我们在中场休息时聊过高尔夫球。所以你不是……你们俩都打。我们打，肖恩不打。肖恩会开车。
Jason I play yeah Sean did come to a golf tournament with us once but he did not play You're not good because you don't play that much because you're working all the time. Yes Yeah, I'm not consistent enough like when I'm on one. It's good Yeah, I'm not consistent enough. Like when I'm on one, it's good to do. All right, looks like we lost him again. Please stand by. By the way, you know, there are certain names, right, that have a cache, that have a thing.
杰森，我打，对。肖恩确实跟我们一起去过一次高尔夫球锦标赛，但他没下场打。你打得不好是因为你没怎么打，因为你整天都在拍戏。对。对，我不够稳定，只要状态在线的时候，它就打得挺好。对，我不够稳定。只要状态在线的时候，打起来还不错。好吧，看来我们又把他给弄丢了。请大家稍候。顺便说一句，你知道的，有些名字天生自带光环，自带某种气场，对吧？
Nick Holt. Nicholas Holt sounds like a star name. That's a star name. Sure it is. You know what I mean? You know, let me, can I run one by you that I don't think is? It's just impossible. I'm gonna say my name.
尼克·霍尔特。尼克·霍尔特听上去就像个巨星的名字。那就是个巨星的名字。当然是了。你懂我的意思吗？你知道吗，我能拿我的名字来举个反例吗？根本不可能。我来说我自己的名字。
Will Arnett is just something that's just, it's sort of like, oh, well that's fine. That's fine. Sean Hayes. That's kind of boring. It's like, oh, it's kind of foggy. I can't really see through it. It's hazy.
威尔·阿奈特这个名字就属于那种……感觉平平无奇，就是“哦，好吧，也行”。这名字挺普通的。肖恩·海斯。这就有点无聊了。感觉就像是个……雾气蒙蒙的，我根本看不透。雾里看花。
You can't make anything out of it. Sean Hayes sounds like your sister's friend, you know? Who's like a graphic designer. You know who I saw at the mall? It's not Sean Hayes. Fucking Sean Hayes. Oh yeah, I remember him from high school, that's it. He sounds like somebody, like your sister's friend
你从这名字里琢磨不出什么名堂。肖恩·海斯听上去就像你姐姐的朋友，你知道吗？就是那种当平面设计师的人。你猜我在商场看到谁了？不是肖恩·海斯。他妈的肖恩·海斯。哦对，我想起来了，他是高中那个谁，没错。这名字听上去就像是那种人，你姐姐在高中时的朋友，
from high school, and now you're 50, and you're like, oh yeah, I thought that guy died. Yeah, sadly that's true. Nick Holt. Nick Holt? Nick Holt is back, oh, sadly that's true. Nick Holt. Nick Holt? Nick Holt is back. He's not back. And more frozen than ever.
然后现在你都50岁了，你会心想：“哦对，我还以为那家伙早就死了呢。”对，遗憾的是这确实是真的。尼克·霍尔特。尼克·霍尔特？尼克·霍尔特回来了，哦，遗憾的是这确实是真的。尼克·霍尔特。尼克·霍尔特？尼克·霍尔特回来了。他没回来。而且比以往任何时候卡得更厉害了。
Yeah. Robbie, is he trying to join back in? No, I just heard from him and I think there's something going on with his laptop. Well, listen, we lost Nicholas Holt. We have got a real spotty connection there. But you want to know what, a guy that busy, we're thankful to get even the amount of time
对。罗比，他是在尝试重新连进来吗？没有，我刚收到他的消息，我觉得他的笔记本电脑出了一些状况。好吧，听着，我们跟尼古拉斯·霍尔特失联了。那边的网络连接实在太糟糕了。不过你知道吗，像他这么忙的人，我们能抽到这么长时间进行交流就已经很感激了，对吧？
that we had, right? Yeah, I agree. And this guy is a talent and a charmer, and again, the hair did not disappoint, the jawline did not disappoint. No, no, no. Good looking guy. Good looking guy, very well spoken, super talented, he's got it all, he's got the superstar name.
对，我同意。而且这家伙不仅有天赋还很有魅力，再说一次，他的发型没让人失望，他的下颌线也没让人失望。对，对，对。长得真帅。长得真帅，口才极好，超级有才华，他简直具备了一切，他拥有巨星般的名字。
Focused, like you said, Jay picks the right projects with the right people. And I'm glad we didn't exhaust him because he's got a lot of talking to do in the coming months. Everyone's going to go out and see Superman. Yeah, we're going to see Superman. What was the date?
专注，就像你说的，杰伊，他总是能和对的人合作，挑选对的项目。我很高兴我们没有把他累坏，因为接下来几个月他还有很多话要说。所有人都会去看《超人》的。对，我们要去看《超人》。上映日期是什么时候来着？
Was it July 11th, did he say? July 11th, yeah. Will anyone beat Scottie to the theater? For Superman? No, I'm not even kidding. He's probably already bought his tickets. Not even joking. He brought something up on his phone last night, Willie.
他是说7月11日吗？7月11日，对。有人能在斯科蒂之前冲进电影院吗？为了看《超人》？没有，我甚至不是在开玩笑。他大概已经把票买好了。我真不是开玩笑。他昨晚用手机调出了个东西，威利。
Oh yeah. And I'm over his shoulder and right there, his screensaver on his iPhone is just the Superman badge, you know, the chest badge. That's his screensaver. I know, he's a big nerd. He's a big fat nerd. Not fat, but he's a nerd.
哦，对。然后我凑到他肩膀旁边一看，好家伙，他iPhone的锁屏壁纸居然就是超人的胸前标志，就是那个胸标，你知道的。那是他的锁屏壁纸。我知道，他是个超级书呆子。他是个大胖书呆子。倒不是说他胖，但他绝对是个书呆子。
That's so funny. That's a great, nerd is a great way to put's a nerd. That's funny, that's a great, nerd is a great way to put it. Yeah. It's not the word I'd use. Right. You know what I mean? Mine starts with an L.
太搞笑了。太棒了，“书呆子”这个词用来形容……真是个绝妙的形容。太搞笑了，书呆子真是个绝妙的词。对。这可不是我会用的词。没错。你知道我的意思吗？我用的词以L开头。
Yeah. A big L. Yeah. Remember when people just, remember nerds all of a sudden sort of appropriated the word, losers appropriated the word nerd, because they thought like they'd make them sound better, and they're just losers.
对。一个大写的L。对。还记得以前人们……还记得书呆子们突然开始把这个词据为己有吗？失败者们把“书呆子”这个词抢了过去，因为他们觉得这能让听起来好听点，而他们其实就是一群失败者。
Well, I'm going to write this down and make sure Scotty knows what he feels. No, I'm kidding, I love Scotty. Where does dork live in that list? Is that more pejorative? Yeah, dork is like that. I'm a loser too. I'm like a hardcore fan who's bummed out
好吧，我要把这个记下来，确保斯科蒂知道他是怎么想的。不，开玩笑的，我可喜欢斯科蒂了。在这类词里，“怪胎”（dork）排在什么位置？这个词贬义更重吗？对，怪胎就像那种。我其实也是个失败者。我就像那种因为昨晚体育比赛输了而懊恼不已的
about a sports game last night. Like that doesn't exactly make me a fucking winner. No, but you know what I was going to say, how good looking Nick Holt is, and I said to Will the other day. Back off the mic a little bit. I said if you're attracted. Look at the tee up, look at the tee up.
死忠球迷。这可绝对不能让我显得像个他妈的赢家。不，不过我正要说的是，尼克·霍尔特长得有多帅，我前几天还对威尔说过呢。离麦克风稍微远一点。我说如果你对……看这个抛出的梗，看这个抛出的梗。
If you're attracted to, uh-huh. If you're attracted to both men and women, but neither are attracted to you. You are by yourself. Oh, nice. Bye. Bye. Bye.
如果你对男人和女人都感兴趣，但他们两个群体对你都不感兴趣。那你就是孤家寡人一个。哦，漂亮。再见。再见。再见。
I like that. We'll accept that. Bye. Bye. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
我喜欢这个。我们接受这个说法。再见。再见。精辟。精辟。精辟。精辟。
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
精辟。精辟。精辟。精辟。精辟。精辟。精辟。精辟。
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Less. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Bennett Barbico, Michael Grant Terry and Rob Armjarff. Smart. Less. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
精辟。精辟。精辟。精辟。SmartLess是由班尼特·巴巴科、迈克尔·格兰特·特里和罗布·阿姆杰夫100%有机手工打造的。SmartLess。这期节目还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可留下评论。